we get closer to returning students to
the classroom dealing with physical and
mental health is on the top of lawmakers
minds
ccsd has had more than 20 suicides since
students started learning from home that
was the subject of the first bill taken
up by the senate education committee
today that is senate bill 36
it requires schools to form a committee
that creates a plan
for dealing with epidemics emergency
situations
and the issue of suicide the teachers
union the clark county education
association
all supported the bill
the clark county school district has
experienced a mental health crisis since
the beginning of the school closures
that have resulted in a high number of
student suicides
educators administrators and students
need a plan to help prepare
and risk manage all future crises
emergencies and epidemics as we return
to in-person
and high-revised hybridized excuse me
learning
now no vote was taken today but both
health health districts around the state
did support the bill
as well